wir verstecken uns einfach hier drin
hier kommen hin kommentierten nein warte
warte kommunen kommen informieren bleibt
einfach da geht zu weit zurück du kannst
das wird echt nichts mehr das wird echt
sind wird gar nichts wäre es mit einfach
nur noch jetzt also ich mache jetzt
einfach wie viel gold hast du denn da in
der hunterklasse gar nichts du achtest
du gold plus gemacht
macht ja auch gleich eine das ist ja
echt zum kotzen wie viel eisen hast du
zwei müssen wir die beiden geben ich
habe noch drei ja ich mache jetzt mal
eisenstadt hast du das kann heißen
schwer tun sagte du hast schon mit kies
haben welche ich habe ich kann dir da
ich habe auch eine künstliche gefunden
ich mache mir erst mal ein brot
altersklassen es werden wollen alles
verbrannt als aussteller vor wir wären
da wieder hin gekommen
nein also passiert aber wir waren auch
wer hätte damit rechnen können dass
diese abgesehen dass ich vielleicht der
vergiftung so etwa 4 gold drin nämlich
erstmal raus das eisentor die drei da
rein macht jetzt auch noch mal eine
goldgrube
ich habe mich ja schon eine so also hier
fällt eine hose hast du noch reisen
zumindest 1 1 eisen ich habe gar keine
mehr aber man kann aus hose und eisen
nicht mischen oder letzte spiel
geschlossen
okay wie geschlossen
die daten chat geschenkt habe mal kurz
alle sachen die wir haben sozusagen
jetzt nächste folge bei denen börse
kommt noch nicht fest warten wir haben
zwei verschiedene arten von pilzen sich
gerade und holz haben wir nicht fakt wir
haben einfach gibt es viel kartoffeln
obst kabine gefunden ja wir brauchen
holz damit wir uns allerdings machen
können naja eigentlich geschlossen im
kampf um zu holen war bei mir auch
es zählt sz eltern erst bei mir noch
sagen soll und jetzt zählt auf einmal
nicht ich habe nochmal zwei davon
gefunden
du hast ja ein tool er gemacht fackeln
oder holz da musst du oben gehen ja ich
bin auch ganz schön oben ich suche jetzt
irgendwie holz dann wieder vergibt die
kartoffel 91 nicht ich habe ja noch eine
gebackene kartoffeln sich gerade als
essbar ist ein holz ihr müsst uns 80
schatten ich muss uns einfach eisen
wieder suchen wir wochen reisen
zumindest aus meiner hose kriegen
vielleicht lieber wenigstens einen platz
wenn ich war mir natürlich eine
spitzhacke persönlich aus stein was mich
so was mich sondern so ein bisschen
aufgeregt war das als gemeint wurde
jetzt zu ende jetzt geht's los hier
blabla ja das dann den er uns mag
einfach noch eine viertelstunde eine
halbe stunde länger noch weiter unten
waren oder fast alle andern halt auch
die waren echt lange unten also ein
bisschen kaka dann die hätten geglaubt
werden ein daumen ich habe schon zweimal
mit pfeilen getroffen
das heißt er hatte ja schon grund
schaden und dann habt ihr hatten wir
beide diesen sport war alleine zu dem
zeitpunkt dann muss es genau in dem
moment ausgehen ich glaub nicht tritt
eine ziege wirklich
es liegt auch nur an forscher das
passiert nie das und gemeinschaft aus
bruder so haben wir noch diese komischen
pflanzen da die wie tortoise sind ich
weiß nicht ob ich habe jetzt wieder im 4
eisen gefunden wenn ich noch eins finde
habe ich zumindest schon mal ein eisen
hose er ich gehe jetzt erstmal ein paar
mushrooms wo bist du wie ihr nicht
reingekommen
ok weiter wo bist du herkommst schweißte
mal vier sachen hin aber ich war wie
gesagt noch was essen trennt messi oder
das eisen das haben wir vor nicht
abgebaut weiß nicht ob das gut
ja das ist gut ich habe ja schon meine
hose suchte am besten jetzt schon lange
hose erwarte hier genau ich gebe euch
von der spitzhacke ich habe eine
spitzhacke wartet wenig verschwenden ich
geb dir du suchst dir ressourcen ich
zähle gleich zusammen wie viel du noch
brauchst so ich habe wie viel 1234 noch
folge flash dass wir gestorben sind hier
du brauchst nur drei eisen finden dann
haben was gut und am besten jetzt nicht
mehr sprinten erstmals den kohle nämlich
auch noch mit keine cola sich holz
verbänden oder leitern verbringen ist
ein holz auf keinen fall verbrennen
leitern geht nicht
bücherregale geht man noel sagte dass
wir gestorben sind
das war das war nur die software wir
hätten wenigstens bad weg gekriegt wir
hätten wir müssen und das nächste mal
auf jeden fall auf beide draufgehen sage
ich mir also nicht erst mal nur auf
einen meine ich wahnsinnig auf beide
dich dass jeder einnimmt sondern dass
beide erstmal auf ein gehöft weiter auf
dem gleichen ja ich habe weder mit einem
pfeil getroffen spark hat auch ein fall
kassiert dann bist du auf party habe
aufs parkett einmal geschlagen und dann
war mein motto down auf mich kein
komischer wolff von der wolff ja die hat
noch so wolf wir haben noch genug da
waren ja nur wie man sich zehn wölfe
gezähmt ist noch ob jeder einschlag
macht der täter am zeiger werden noch so
viel machen können dass auch eigentlich
richtig blöd das wird dass diese
diamanten schuhe gemacht haben vor allem
die habe jetzt aber diese man diese
diamanten
die haben sogar schuhe wir hatten glaube
wir haben verzauberung die am amboss
bekommen wir haben alles gekriegt die
haben wir ja beide sachen jetzt ja etwas
gefunden
im jahr 2000 nur einer fehlt noch nur
noch thomas epp links und blumen rein
und ich hoffe das geht auch das brennt
nicht chaplins band läuft
scheiß koblenz stirbt hatten gold nugget
fällen das was bringt ein goldnuggets
1,5 an diesem scheiß koblenz da ich habe
ich soko lars sowieso mitgenommene ja
kohle habe ich mit ihr haben und nicht
mehr verschwenden
so jetzt eine hose allgemeine christoph
klotter aus rheda zu reisen hofmeister
auch richtig so multikulti airport mit
zusammengeschrumpft ist
wir brauchen eben fackeln ja ich habe
hier fackel noch ihr set game to peace
voll geil ist der zombie weg den ich
dort töten wollte
was die regen sich um alles zu recht ich
habe noch ein eisen gefunden kann
zurückkommen
okay bin auf dem weg geht das brennt
offensichtlich nicht nur irgendwas was
brennt am 26 keys rein darf 36 noch
nicht die ganze city zweck wir brauchen
auch fackeln jetzt auch noch also gut
solange die potenten manchmal piano
stick ist hier so ein baum witzig ist
dann eben gleich hier finden so spiele
stick ist hier bestimmt wo bist du
ich bin auf dem weg ich bin auch so ein
depp hier ist kohle direkt neben mir
aber nicht verbrannt wie stickies
hegermann baum mit die gis kaputt ich
bin diese liebe diese hat gut zusammen
kräften in sechs metern in der kiste
hier muss auch den eisernen rhein tun
ok ich hab' noch sechs kohle ich hab
noch diese komischen torch berisha
sticks für mich nicht nur verzweifeln
die frage ist die werden was jemals
wieder schaffen
diamant spitzhacke zu bekommen nein wir
werden allgemein nichts mehr schaffen
das ist jetzt alles nur
arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme reich werde
jetzt auch kein putzi modus spielen dass
wir ganze zeit unter boden bleiben und
keiner sieht
das war scheiße hat dann stellen london
ich mache jetzt kaputt
damit keiner mehr draus machen kann
staub gemacht
einfach nur schon mal sicherheitshalber
so ich mache jetzt meine hose eine
gemütliche einen keuschheitsgürtel aus
eisen
ich habe diesmal mit dem sound danke
die stacks mal mit kohle ausgetauscht
daran uns noch zwei gold- schwerter
mache nicht optimal mehr schaden oder
reisen macht mir schon wirklich ich habe
jetzt sechs eisen wenn das im ofen
fertig ist daraus kann ich mir eine
schule machen uns also auf jeden fall
kann uns noch erst noch in eisen immer
da ich kann es noch ein feuerzeug man
aber wenigstens die welt noch ein
bisschen tonnen nachschub kommt noch
machen
auch damals mir schuhe aus gold einfach
sollte ja mehr protect oder wie viel
hast du ich habe eins noch dann geht mir
das mal bitte heben sondern verarbeitet
hier ja dann packe ich dass da eben
gleich rein wenn du fertig das protected
gold mehr als eisen nein also nicht mehr
als im leder
ja ist genau gleich wie steiner hält
nicht so lange stein ich denke an die an
die dinge ins an die genau so wie es ist
nicht ist genauso wie auch keine ahnung
ich glaube damit nicht leute deshalb
wäre ich will eigentlich sagen schon
oder
wir müssen auf jeden fall reisen finden
einfach dann kann man es dann kann ich
meine brust 'bitte machen ja ich habe ja
noch keine beine aus dienst dann will
ich noch einen großbagger der partner
ich laufe einfach mal den weg hier
weiter abwesend wie stickies ich hab 27
da war es doch eher bei das volleyball
das holz aus holz gut ich bin ziemlich
er wieder komplett vor anderen zu
kreisen
aber ich meine jetzt einfach hier ein
enger knüpfen wir einfach voll aus eisen
und dann machen wir wieder attacke will
ich sagen oder
ja wir schaffen nicht ab aber sie allein
und hier dieser müssen väter da muss ja
auch nicht sein
aber was ist eigentlich an sky findet
diese map wenn man wirklich monster an
ich hielte und sich wirklich
durchkämpfen muss glaube ich ist das ja
richtig geil hier ist ein höhle
das war glaube ich richtig geil oder wer
auch eigentlich aber man dass sich die
diamanten für die schuhe benutzte ob es
recht ungünstig ja was hat man sonst
machen sollen abwertend für eine
verzauberung zu stecken müssen habe ich
wirklich nicht dran gedacht
bei male das war der gleiche wie beim
battle da hatte ich durch einen zufalls
drop eine karotte gefunden hat seinen
preis stand hatte unsichtbarkeit senke
sogar massiv wehrte geschwindigkeit
stärke und sichtbarkeit tränke dann
haben wir gefeiert welchen und
sichtbarkeit angegriffen genau dann sind
sie abgelaufen wir sind drauf gegangen
ach mensch ich bin leichter bei der
kiste vermerk das ist ungünstig jetzt
reisen zu finde ich das gleich noch die
spitzhacke kaputt ist also ich habe
jetzt hier noch sechs reisen gefunden
also
die hälfte grant hart jawoll hundehalter
wenn jetzt wirklich raus und das ist ja
schon mal gestorben
ich habe gold gefunden wie bisher keine
gold sachen machen jetzt schon gestorben
homing karte irgendwo geklettert
ciro nicht doch klar nein nein wenn sein
team kollege noch lebt dann es geht ja
nur um response zwei response so ja ok
deswegen wenn einer halb zwei mal stirbt
dann darf der andere halt noch
weiterspielen so lange bis er stirbt
okay aber solo ist schon wirklich größer
also bin ich jetzt noch diamanten finde
ich raste aus
quatsch wir waren im wasser
und jetzt fällt kommen den tod vom staat
bauherr wieder schreibt die wal im
wasser
kann doch nichts für die bucks im motto
spring abgestürzt oder so ich hab auch
noch eingefunden
eins aber nur egal ich komme wieder
zurück zur küste zu weit weg war kein
spaß mehr
komm lass gleich einfach rausgehen er
das auch auf blöd wenn das in der höhle
bleiben ja ich mache mir aber eine
komplette goldrichtig ich sehe ich da
ist dick ist ich glaube ich habe ich
nicht hier waren war doch kein eisen
haben will
vergreift sich an bord des schiffes
dickem blut place und
nur ob sind da haben wir müssen uns
aufbauen und laufen direkt ja jetzt
kommt da kommen hier zur küste hin offen
weg aber ich muss mich in bonn dauert
die haben es nicht gesehen laufen
beckloff weglaufen weg jacob doch wer
von anderen seite ich wette die jungen
hier alle um die abo zwischen länger
beobachtet die laufen weg jetzt läuft es
wieder hierhin hast du das in eisernen
ofen gepackt doch nicht mein eisernen
ofen gepackt also sechs stücke in mir
ich bin zumindest ein helm draus machen
die kombinierte schaffen auf gar keinen
fall
rauslaufen wir verstecken uns einfach
hier drin hier komm ich hinkomme hast du
klingst tor wartet werte waren kommen
bleibt einfach da geht so weit zurück
wie du kannst noch ein stück zurück kann
ich nicht da sind noch die kings
nirgends liegen
das ist so spannend
aufzubauen doch das schaffen wir
schaffen das nicht dass man unter genau
an der richtigen stelle ja schlagen kann
stangls gegenseitig kaputt kommen da
unten durchschlagen
okay aber das war war trotzdem nette
runde ich dachte wir haben ein team aus
dem rheingau ja okay wir haben ein team
aus dem rennen gehauen sind dann fast
noch mal für den anderen gegangen als
wir müssen jetzt auf jeden fall unter
vom server ja und ich würde einfach
sagen und zum nächsten mal wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr eine positive bewertung
da lassen es wird es auf jeden fall
freuen
bis zum nächsten mal vielleicht kommt
mehrere team battles und ja es macht
coach otto